the UK government hates immigrants
but it also seems to hate its own citizens
they have made an announcement that they want to increase
the minimum salary threshold for skilled worker visas
as well as family visas
in addition to already increasing the healthcare surcharge
that you have to pay when you process your visa application
from £600 per year to £1,000 per year
the increase to the salary threshold is a kick in the teeth to a lot of people
because they didn't just increase it by £1,000 or two no
the family visa salary threshold was originally
I believe £18,600
and the skilled worker visa salary threshold was around £27,000 per year
the new threshold
for both of these two completely different visas is now £38,700 per year
and for reference
for those of you who don't know UK salaries
the average salary in the UK is around 30,000 pounds per year
so to contextualize
let's say that you're an American
and the average salary is 65,000 a year
I don't know if that's true
I'm just using that number as a reference
and this would be like saying if you want to bring your spouse over
you yourself have to earn 80,000 a year
anyone who earns less than that
would not be able to bring their spouse or fiance over
I say that the UK government doesn't respect its own citizens
because if you are a British person who happens to fall in love with foreigner
the government is now basically punishing you if you don't earn enough money
they're essentially separating families and tearing them apart
this threshold increase was announced at the start of the week
and the government has basically said that they plan to
implement these changes by spring of 2024
so they're not even giving people a full year to acclimate
to this massive increase in their salary that they somehow need to suddenly make
I been seeing posts of people who have their weddings planned for May or April
who are now trying to find the fastest route possible to get married
and get their visa processed before any of these changes can take place
and I have been seeing even more heartbreaking posts
from people who are now unsure of their future
they're not sure if they're ever gonna be able to live with
the person that they've loved
a lot of these people who have been saving up for years
who have been making these plans for years now
don't even know if they're going to be able to stay with their partner
and live in the place that they want to live in
the fortunate thing is
at least for people who already have their spousal visa
and/or are already living and working in the UK
is that they can at least combine their salaries to make this £38,700 total
but if you live in
if you're a UK citizen
and you live in the UK
and your spouse lives in
like Guatemala or something
you yourself have to make that £38,700 a year
you can't combine incomes with anything else
and then something like
if you wanna pay with your cash savings
it's tens of thousands of pounds
which again if you don't have a high salary
you're probably not gonna have that much in your savings right
let's say that you're on a skilled worker visa in the UK
and your visa is set to expire within a year
and you're only earning £27,000 a year
now suddenly
you have to worry about getting a £10,000 raise within a year
in order to renew your visa and stay
(if that's your specific case)
it's already so difficult and frustrating to try and get a work sponsorship visa
if you're a student who wants to stay in the UK afterwards
so now the government has basically been like “oh
it's already difficult
for someone to be willing to go through all these extra hoops to sponsor you?
now you also have to make a good deal more than the average salary
if you even wanna establish your life here”
I understand that it's necessary to routinely increase these salary thresholds
with the cost of living going up
and in theory
the government wants to prove that families can financially support themselves
that if you're coming over to work
that you're actually boosting the industry that you're working for
it's just ironic that a country that wanted to go
it's ironic that a country that colonized half the world
is so anti immigration
and is doing everything it really can
to try and keep people from immigrating there